if I had to guess it would be very
different than the men married today the
other issue is is they downplay the
difference in the time period that we
are in most women have been addicted to
attention from the time they were very
very young this creates a completely
different pool of women that men have to
choose from the women are more
and overweight than ever and really when
we don't acknowledge these things and
tell men to just get married with a
system that profits off of them having
their lives ruined it there's no real
solution because you're not even
acknowledging the problem you're
downplaying that it exists I would argue
that is negligent um the single most
important foundation for a lasting
marriage I would agree commonality of
values however I do not think that is a
foolproof plan